hoje é minha vida um carro mais fácil
hoje um de ovos uma família da pesada
caminho porque um dia assim que uma
parte que eu vou dizer pra vocês que
resolvi fazer a universidade tem a ver
com um soco no estômago que é meu que eu
estou falando senão solitário e outros
que também na pelo ted é compartilhada
alternativas de educação jogada bonita e
importante nessa linha 1a eu fui 10 na
amazônia em 2010 que mudou minha vida
então um estádio pra mim é muito
emocionante porque o partido como oscar
tem a ver mais aplicada
e esse evento só para despesas fazem com
a gente é eu fiz o caminho que o álbum
diz que é inevitável a sociedade e as
famílias têm que dar a relação no estado
do colorado
sou designer mesma pessoa a pessoa e
coordenador do curso de design e é
engraçado porque eu fiz a minha carreira
de estudante que é uma carreira tivesse
um dinheiro e principalmente sonhos na
história toda a rede particular a última
educação muito boas oportunidades
é enfim todas as fotos dos amigos mais e
festas juninas de coisas fossem passar
com o estudante até eu chegar lá ela vai
prestar vestibular em 2005 você vai
fazer outras são paulo a vai pra onde
a oficina é sucateada a instituição
interessada passado
muita coisa é certa no mercado ficar em
uma vitória
eu gosto daqui o seu desejo de que a
família não tem que ir embora pra poder
voltar depois e agora como a renda na
verdade é que eu não faço isso
então eu vou contar pra vocês um pouco
dessa história eu trabalhei na camiseta
eu fui pra uso estudar e da primeira
turma o cisne pelo entrei no olho do
furacão inclusive para as coisas
estruturadas aqui eu estou chutando
mundo todo a gazeta a volta aqui então
mais a gente gostava muito de registrar
nosso contentamento com a tecnologia
sabe como o cabelo estava dizendo que o
prédio é foi a minha vida ea minha vida
16 anos e mãe de quatro eu amo esse
lugar maravilhoso modernista
o marcelo teve a posse de verdade e eu
passei a minha isso de minha vida toda
para chegar é lixo na computadores e
estudar aqui e aqui já terminou o
mestrado em dois amigos importantíssimos
e aqui eu tenho a minha defesa do
doutorado tem um único que então resumo
a minha vida acadêmica nos esforço no
verde das vezes com o nosso coca com
essas flores é indiferença não é
possível que a universidade está aqui
que a universidade é pública é muito
importante também mas é uma coisa mais
recente ele 30 mil alunos ou seja 10% a
uma vitória dentro do campus
produzindo nada sendo inútil
quer dizer há rodas sim de encontrar
coisas positivas revolucionários
interessantes apaixonada da república
ela tem um papel importante no
desenvolvimento do estado aí só que
existe cinha ser alternativo que parece
estar mais preocupado com pay per view
nas gavetas e ponte alta a unidade ea
minha idéia é abrir as portas da
universidade pública
coisas de qualidade emitido poder
continuar a tentar fazer alguma coisa
com o desenvolvimento do estado do país
a gente pode dizer de certa forma que a
universidade é publicada em uma crise de
imagem assim né
eu via isso como vestibular vai fazer os
que vai transmitir aquela ainda assim só
um país né nas letras médicos
então eu era aquele cara que ficava
desenhando mas na sala eu tomo cuidado
médico unimed que assim está fora e aí
não esteve por ser professor de desenho
passar fome duas vezes nelas o acesso
ainda por cima está tudo junto na sua
muita conversa o que ele entende que ele
publica hoje é isso aí e jornais greve
está fechando com alta qualificação a 1
sem aula
mas é isso já diz 30 mil caras estão a
minar 11 esse tempo todo estudando não
só retornou e que días não concedeu a
ordem de interromper no caminho
também é isso mas é e aí a gente pode
explicar ou reduzir todo o esforço de
produção do conhecimento
as iniciativas de gaveta ou dificuldades
quando aparecer na televisão alguns
aparecem na gravação revelada
eventualmente aparece que nem é o caso
nem assim as suas tão minutos e minutos
de replay desse negócio e discutir a
contribuição fundamental que esses caras
estão fazendo lá ouvindo está é mais
legal mostrar todo mundo saiu pelada que
fazer um esforço que foi aplaudida
trabalho sabe a gente é difícil piauí
sinto o motorista então vamos lá
ao mesmo tempo é eu quando aparece uma
situação por exemplo de erro a gente vai
falar porque eu sou universitário nem
isso porque o professor fez tal coisa
sala de aula a gente gosta tem prazer em
declínio em mais funcional e comecei a
pensar é possível né passei 16 anos da
minha vida continuava a apresentar por
lá sendo professor e eu pensei é ter
alternativa é uma alternativa é muito
simples eu comecei a pensar que o seu
designer e poder deixar a vida toda
aquela coisa que eu tenho minha vida eu
tenho e trabalha e se ele sair eu pensei
essa coisa tá nessa saída já tá na moda
nos últimos 10 15 anos usava vai mudar o
mundo está em geral as pessoas a invadir
aquele cara que é uma coisa legal mas as
pessoas colocam a mão na massa ea gente
precisa sempre o outro né
antes de se permitir que o outro usuário
e europa
o dunga está trabalhando é muito
importante uma coisa poderá acontecer e
eu vi um potencial interessante de
transformação a partir dessa perspectiva
eu acho que a gente pode pensar que
primeira coisa é se é possível imaginar
que se tem também duas universidades
pedro pessoas consertados 11 uma verdade
nadinha lá ea gente pode dizer mais nada
a grade de pensar que nós podemos então
fazer essa passagem levar a gente para
dentro e sair pra tentar trocar esse
mundo é eu pensar e motivar pessoas
pessoas
as pessoas são a razão de existir
universidade
eu sempre saio foto assim um monte de
gente nova
motivada animado no porque cem alunos e
estudantes em alagoinha o termo nem
pensamos em buscar o aluno nessas
iluminar o futebol ganhe confessor
grande para oc domingo você você é a
pessoa melhor e não o contrário
a razão do dia do professor da
universidade da escola é aquele que
aprender a aprender porque fábio então
eu sempre tentei é na mina nos quais as
duas cidades de cerca de mais nova do
que eu
muito mais interesse do que eu uma
energia do que eu e provavelmente sabem
muito mais aquilo que a gente começa a
estudar as peças há muito você vai
aprendendo né eu sei muito menos dois no
mundo todo que eu sabia que não era
aluno de infância muito menos um golo na
tentativa de responder poderia
atravessar uma rua próxima de gente nova
a cheia de perguntas e respostas e
tiveram de caminhar e andar a essas
respostas rj antes do evento a gente
mudou muita coisa enorme muito rápido do
cérebro uma mariola e um papelzinho
a agenda pelo interior trabalhar com ela
todos familiares um design já não chega
ea gente tenta transformar até a sala de
aula e tentavam parar dentro da sala de
aula mas a governar mal dinho não é
simbólica
sai da favela um corretor deixa as
pessoas vão para o novo está dizendo e
usar o índice ainda está passando também
por suspensão
a segunda coisa que é muito importante é
oferecer acesso de acesso o acesso à
universidade mas acesso a conhecimento
acesso a pessoas que são um eh eh
importantes acesso a tecnologias de
acesso a pessoas que possam colaborar
se fosse eu acho que uma coisa que é eu
tenho que conseguir por exemplo levar os
meninos lá pelo interior exibe uma
semana na propriedade rural e em
qualidade que irão trabalhar porque o
agricultor pensa como ele demanda é de
sair como ele poderia trocar a peça um
situações para poder aprender coisas que
a sala de aula não mostra mas também
terá espaço físico também que dar
problema a gente começou o projeto os
alunos repensar a imagem desenhar marca
médio estão ali têm muitas histórias
bacanas no inside alunos que construiu
as costas professores a cadeia e sempre
se desenhar o que muda em relação à
cadeira então com todo mundo deles eles
têm que conversar sobre isso e também em
sala de aula nessa questão a música
desenvolvendo instrumentos para
economizar água maltina out e fotografia
então estão à venda especial acontecendo
e se alguém fazer alguma coisa são as
fazem não é dá acesso é em quem sai da
frente que começou na frente né
cada prova é difícil chamar a vossa
milhões mundial tinha acabado de fazer
dando um
engenharia misturado e tenha 11 primeiro
período fazer um sistema de boa tabela
está condicionado a economizar nos
prédios e altera a redação primeiro
período no projeto museu está esse
menino aqui que assim portugal está
pedro começa a trabalhar não olha que
agora faz o óbvio pois é mas eu estava
já dava valor ainda não disse aquilo eu
fiquei ajudando eles andarem sai da
frente a isso nem conseguiria se
quiserem construir e aí eu acho uma
coisa mais bacana que apreendidas três
pontos é a idéia de que nossa
universidade com todo mundo
a música tem sido raptada realidade ou
seja aquele caso de todo o mundo real
para serem resolvidos mas não separando
um pecado eu pegar o portãozinho da onça
centavos canos não derruba o portão um
nível problema ou visão pela unidos ele
vai pensar como resolver este problema
nós mesmos
a pesquisa não pode ser só precisa de
gaveta é importante mas o conhecimento
produzido na interação com a comunidade
que tipo de coisa eu posso fazer ou não
qual o governo federal investir 16 anos
da vida de 22 minha vida 2 do mestrado e
quatro doutorados
vou pesquisar o que eu quero é que goes
mesmo né
o dinheiro de vocês paulo - tudo o que
eu posso devolver pra vocês que cada
estudante fala da república pode
envolver e eu vou ver como se fosse uma
moeda de troca não o que pode se
envolver e se engaja afinal a
universidade nessa questão de
conhecimento ea extensão que é mais
complicado gente extensão pirata
eu vou arrumar foi a extensão saquei
porque ele volta hoje a universidade não
levou nada então os convidados não chega
os cubos de artesãos e produtores só
assim a três universidades aparecido
aqui vieram precisaram foi embora e
nunca mais voltar
não quero
mas muda isso
esse é um grupo importante eu tenho uns
30 meninos de rock de hoje lá
trabalhando com as coisas que eles
querem trabalhar e metade os nomes dos
grupos estão se organizando no ordenado
sobre o organismo
na verdade eu tomaria saiu corrido não
resolverem enfim são articulados é um
grupo com os 17 jatos 30 ea gente chegou
num desses depois de seis anos na
universidade francesa que na ufc em 2009
35 anos não tenho quase mais tempo de
dispersão investigou e até hoje do dente
do siso no mesmo canal todos os de casa
onde cheguei nessa idéia de se estressar
transforme pessoal não diz como é a vida
pessoal dos meus alunos
eu gostaria muito de ter sua marca de
mais gente eu acho que a universidade é
esse analisar neste também comemorou a
abertura à comunidade é parte do ártico
parte lá em 2010 2011 do projeto de
gestão e também à lua brilhando para faz
lá e depois de design vão trabalhar em
busca do título é do dem ou se distrair
a atenção para a salgadeira e twitter
pode sim é a extensão das pessoas
tentando melhorar os produtos delas usou
desabafa inquérito todos lá ensina
métodos e tecnologias a mesma que ele
sabe fazer aqui o seu luiz que é um país
queijo há 50 anos uma mesma receita que
chamou a prima de ponta de asa também
visa a vigilância sanitária de lado
deixar de fabricar esse que de veneza o
mercado sem aparecer na tradição local
monte azul e branco tirar a história de
não fazer isso então ele me dizer como
querem ser feita aqui a juliana por aí
olha que ela estava na nossa que volta a
não poder falar e do aberto a 1 saiu
continuando de volta para poder
a gente também fica pela metade já que
saiu de lado o time está evoluindo e até
o riso não protege agora falar da bósnia
os meninos novos governantes do nosso eu
estava à vontade cá dentro em breve a
universidade
segunda coisa autonomia o estudante
decidiu aprender ou não eu vou prometer
segunda vez em um grande espaço para
dizer olha eu nem economia mas é certo
que a onde e não o que um livro texto
qualquer física e tem que ser discutida
porque eu aprendi uma coisa muito forte
as pessoas aprendem melhor mas não
envolvida afetivamente no processo não
gostava da fazenda a quem gosta de comer
e dormir demasiado está também obrigado
é uma coisa que vai fazer não vai
funcionar
e aí eu tenho alunos do primeiro período
os seis projetos que economizam o rolete
a universidade primeiro período saiu
para fazer o download do espaço deles e
eles o nariz dela fosse você implantados
assim externo e por fim a população
ninguém trabalha sozinho eu preciso
necessariamente eu entendi isso muita
força articular universidade
o mesmo e comunidade que forma junto lá
em são francisco partes da cisco
nordeste espírito santo que o projeto
ajudou mais outro de desviar o olhar
essa possam entender o que estou falando
eu tenho o vice-prefeito abaixado no
canto
eu tenho a diretora do ídolo aqui no
meio é morena
os meus alunos de uma série de culto e
jô a gente convenceu a prefeitura a
criar uma feira modelo os produtos da
indústria
o ift lá que é uma base de arroz não
chega mesmo instalar parte do projeto é
a protagonista também articulando as
pessoas oferecendo estrutura nos alunos
tenham uma experiência maravilhosa por
uma semana as propriedades roriz
sobretudo imaginário inclusive
como fazer uma bela colocada uma linha
mas esse conjunto articulado é a única
como eu vejo a necessidade de mudar essa
imagem que ele tem e tentar de alguma
forma resolver essa crise institucional
que é falta de retorno falta de resposta
levou o senhor a da universidade de iowa
como abertura leva a comunidade para
dentro saber distintos néné uma motor de
se sabe muito sobre mim disse pra ele e
nem deixa de acreditar nisso eu tenho
que como universidades e olha os saberes
são coisas totalmente equivalente a 7 cm
verticalmente distintos na vida inteira
lamentando que haja uma forma todos os
instrumentos que construiu toda a
estratégia que ele montou tem valor ea
universidade não posso falar com a lente
da ciência de reservar é ver na popular
que eu faço melhor do que uma vida
inteira eu vou trocar com ele e aprender
um pouquinho cobriram um cada
quando se fala em economia esses alunos
escolheram estar lá os da área sem
receber nada não são músicas já era
noite eu tenho coisas ficavam seis horas
numa banda nova na br para chegar lá
achando bom ele escolheu estava e
principalmente essa articulação e sem a
unidade ao banco unidade vão participar
em desenvolvimento sem governo se
fazendo presentes ainda à frente também
fazer sem sair da frente né
muita gente queria muito agradecer a
oportunidade de devolver à comunidade de
drogas caras vão me dizer a vocês que é
um orgulho nem sempre isso é necessário
mas ao mesmo tempo a universidade ela
não é uma entidade e intocável do
questionava a universidade somos nozes
né quem falasse sobre as costas aos a
universidade de saúde a senhora não vai
resolver mudar
tenho dado meu irmão